who would have ever thought that we
would have a life living in um
technology like we're doing right now
and how can we you know remain humanized
if you've not learned empathy through
this instance um you shouldn't be a
leader right now this is very difficult
we have young mothers who are on Zoom
calls all day while they're trying to
teach a four or fivey old how to get
themselves through a zoom call and get
their lessons done I'm telling you I
feel so blessed that my kids are older
because I'd have to throw in the towel
and we cannot afford to have women not
in the workplace that is just not
acceptable it can't happen we've got to
think of other Solutions one of the
things I've done in my um organization
is that we have no meetings before 9:00
am um because you need to get the kids
settled and get them at least in front
of the laptop and pack a lunch and prop
them up in front of that screen that's
the reality and then we have something
on Fridays called Quick Connect Fridays
and the only thing you're allowed to do
on a Friday is call someone and say
hello um you can't have any business any
serious business meetings um and it's
for you to reflect on the
week recognize people give people
recognition and call and check on
somebody and so we call it quick connect
Fridays and no meetings Monday through
Friday before 9:00 am and that's one of
the things that Co has taught us is to
meet your employee base where they are
and um it's important now and it's going
to be important for a while